c'est tout près du camping de savonnière
sur cette petite route goudronnet que
l'accident s'est produit hier vers 16h30
alors que le lieu est prisé par les
promeneurs du dimanche une BMW
immatriculée en région parisienne arrive
à vivealure le conducteur perd le
contrôle percute ce véhicule avant de
facher trois piétons c'est une route
très peu fréquenté hein c'est un je sais
pas comment on dit un chemin communal
donc la densité de circulation est
faible donc c'est c'est vraiment pas
l'endroit où on s'attend à voir ce genre
de d'accident une dame de 78 ans est
décédée sur le coup son fils et la
compagne de celui-ci sont grièvement
blessé leur pronostic vital est en jeu
l'état de la voiture témoigne de la
violence du choc alors arrivé les
pompiers et les enquêteurs découvrent
une femme au volant qui dit avoir été
ébloui par le soleil aujourd'hui elle
était toujours en garde à vue sa version
est
constante elle prétend que c'est elle
qui est à l'origine de l'accident nous
avons quant à nous un certain nombre
d'éléments extrêmement précis et sérieux
notamment des témoignages qui nous ment
à penser que ce n'est pas elle qui est à
l'origine de l'accident ce serait un
homme qui était au volant de la voiture
les enquêteurs recherche activement le
concubin ainsi que le père de celui-ci
également propriétaire de la voiture les
trois concernés appartiennent à la
communauté des gens du voyage ils
étaient installés dans un camp tout près
du lieu de l'accident qui depuis a
déménagé l'inspection d'hier n'a pas
permis de retrouver le concubin il est
âgé de 32 ans et a déjà connu des
services de police